for has kicked alien butts as a member
of the Avengers spot as a gladiator and
hobnobbed with the guardians of the
galaxy but given his many many
adventures across the nine realms it can
be easy to forget all of his godly
exploits well fear not this is Thor's
entire MCU story finally explained yes
Carol Danvers was the first person to
support the Avenger moniker and Steve
Rogers had the name literally in the
title of his first film but when you
stop to think about it the First Avenger
in the MCU to ever draw breath was Thor
in fact the competition isn't even a
close one
as he Odinson reveals an infinity war
he's 1500 years old by the time the
events of the modern MCU roll around
during that time Thor has functioned as
a Prince of Asgard he's followed the
lead and direction of his father Odin
and spent copious amounts of time
roughhousing with his younger adopted
brother Loki of the original six
Avengers Thor is also unique as the only
member of royalty on the team as well as
the only hero to live off world by the
time he enters the current 21st century
MC timeline
Thor has centuries of experience under
his belt on top of that he's operating
as the heir apparent and shoo-in for the
next king of Asgard but of course things
don't always go according to plan
especially in the MCU by 2011 the aging
Odin is ready to crown his eldest son as
the king of Asgard even if Thor is still
rather narcissistic and headstrong
however the coronation is cut short when
frost giants suddenly appear on the
scene attempting to raid the Royal vault
while the raid fails it prompts Thor to
disobey his father's orders and head to
Jotunheim the frost giants home in order
to exact a little retribution for the
unwelcome disturbance Thor's disregard
for his father's wishes ultimately leads
to Odin stripping his son of power and
banishing him to Midgard a backwater
area of the nine realms of Asgard known
to its inhabitants simply as Earth
[Music]
however as a sign of secret hope for his
son
Odin also sends Thor's magic hammer
mjolnir with him declaring that only one
who is worthy will be able to wield it
on earth Thor meets scientist Erik
Selvig and Jane Foster then eventually
strikes up a romantic relationship with
the latter over time he comes to grips
with his exile and is slowly humbled
until he proves himself worthy of the
hammer as well as his former position on
Asgard
at that point he returns home and
defeats his brother Loki who's usurped
the throne in his absence
Loki ultimately falls to his apparent
death and a contemplative more mature
Thor then resumes his position as his
father's right-hand man accepting that
it isn't his time to rule his king one
short year after Thor returns to Asgard
he sent back to earth by his father not
as an exile though this time he comes
with the express purpose to fetch his
brother Loki after it's discovered the
trickster didn't actually die and is
planning an invasion of Midgar upon his
arrival Thor quickly bumps into the
onion fide team of Avengers immediately
duking it out with Iron Man before
Captain America convinces them that they
shouldn't be fighting each other from
there Thor joins the slowly assembling
team on shields Helicarrier where he
participates in the discussion of what
to do with his brother providing insight
regarding Loki's past the Thunder guard
even helps contain Hulk when the green
machine is accidentally turned loose on
the airship after Loki wreaks havoc on
the carrier and escapes Thor heads to
the Big Apple where he reunites with the
Avengers and participates in the Battle
of New York the Asgardian plays a
thunderous role in the encounter
fighting hordes of Chitauri and trading
blows with his brother yet again when
the dust settles Thor takes both Loki
and the tesseract back to Asgard
although he NAB's a quick bite of
shwarma before he hits the road
after the 2012 events with the Avengers
Thor returns home and spends a good deal
of time traveling the nine realms
intending to Royal business as he takes
care of his responsibilities though he
never stops pining for Jane Foster but
after he asked the all-seeing Heimdall
to check in on her Thor surprised to
discover that his farsighted friend can
no longer see her this revelation Spurs
the prince to return to earth in order
to inquire about the whereabouts and
safety of his sweetheart upon his
arrival he discovers that she's been
possessed by the ether that is the
reality stone in its angry sludge form
concerned Thor brings foster back to
Asgard to receive treatment in the
ensuing chaos the Dark Elves led by
Malekith attack Asgard and killed Thor's
mother Frigga this new threat posed by
the Dark Elves the danger of the ether
inside Jane Foster and the death of his
mother pushed Thor to disobey his father
again he hatches a plan which includes
sneaking out of Asgard with Loki in
order to hunt down Malekith before the
dark elf can literally destroy the
universe with the future drama
surrounding Thanos it's easy to lose
sight of the fact that universe saving
shows up on Thor's resume multiple times
the pursuit eventually leads back to
Greenwich England where Thor defeats
Malekith and does indeed save the
universe the next significant event that
Thor participates in is the war with
Ultron in 2015 he aids in retrieving
Loki's scepter in sokovia and he's
present when Ultron is created in stark
tower after which he lends his strength
to the fight against the runaway robot
in addition to the superhero antics Thor
also heads off on a side quest in order
to learn more about a disturbing vision
that he'd received involving the
Infinity stones he finds Erik Selvig who
takes him to the water of sites where he
learns among other things that a new
beam will help destroy Ultron this
prompts him to bring vision to life upon
his return to the Avengers as the story
winds its way to the climactic events in
sokovia Thor continues to provide muscle
and firepower for the Avengers plans and
ultimately plays a critical role in
foiling Ultron's attempt to exterminate
mankind through a global catastrophe
with the super Android defeated Thor
heads off to continue his investigation
of the Infinity stones
Thor's search for the Infinity stones
proves to be fruitless he and Jane
Foster mutually dump each other and by
2017
he's being haunted by a new series of
dreams this
I'm revolving around Ragnarok and the
destruction of his home world after
exposing Odin as his brother Loki in
disguise the pair travelled to earth in
search of their father Doctor Strange
directs them to Norway where they arrive
in time to have some parting words with
their dad before he passes away while
initially tragic the events soon turn
into a catastrophe as Odin's death
releases their evil sister hella from
thousands of years of imprisonment you
have no idea what's buzzin
Ella quickly shows her superior powers
as she destroys me ol near without
skipping a beat she then prepares to
force her brothers to bow to her so she
can take her place as the rightful ruler
of Asgard at this point Loki mistakenly
summons the Bifrost allowing hellah to
follow them directly to a scart wall and
route she sends the two brothers
hurtling out of the beam and into space
where they're eventually boat deposited
on the garbage planets of Sekar once a
car Thor is captured and forced to fight
as a gladiator in the grandmasters arena
and against his friend from work bulk no
less after their battle he helps Bruce
Banner regain control over Hulk and then
joins with banner Valkyrie and Loki and
a daring escape he leads the ragtag band
called The Revenge errs back to Asgard
where they plan to overthrow hella back
on Asgard The Revenge errs defeat the
goddess of death but only by unleashing
Ragnarok as Thor's home planet implodes
under Surtur's fire heal the god of
thunder escapes with the revenge errs
and the survivors of Asgard on a ship
that's headed for Earth during the short
period of time that leads up to Ragnarok
Thor loses his father his home most of
his people his hammer and even his eye
while in combat with his sister
nevertheless he comes out of the ordeal
ready to lead the remnants of his people
as their king unfortunately the new king
doesn't even finish the trip to earth
before things take an even darker turn I
feel like everything's gonna work out
fine
before Thoren the survivors of asgard
get to earth they're intercepted by
Thanos and his forces the ensuing
encounter leaves half of the Asgardians
including Heimdall and Loki dead the
ship in tattered ruins and Thor floating
through space with little to no chance
of rescue however when all hope seems
lost the guardians of the galaxy
responding to a distress signal arrived
on the scene and saved the king of
Asgard from a chilly death in space once
he regains consciousness Thorin the
guardians discuss Thanos and his plans
with the Infinity stones this leads he
has Guardian to commandeer the ship
space pod and head off towards need of a
leer in search of a weapon to replace
his beloved Neal near Rockets and group
tag along and once the trio gets there
they attempt to convince the dwarf King
and master Smith Eitri to help them
forge the powerful new weapon Eitri is
able to do so but only after Thor
reignites the dormant star Forge and
takes the full force of its heats in
order to keep it operating a feat that
almost kills him armed with the freshly
forged Stormbreaker Thor summons the
Bifrost and hurtles back towards earth
in order to help his allies in fight
Thanos Thor's epic arrival in Wakanda
proves timely penny successfully helps
to subdue the hordes of outriders that
threaten to overwhelm the Wakanda
defenses Thanos arrives in Wakanda in
search of the last infinity stone not
long after Thor and in a last-ditch
effort the king of Asgard proves
stronger than any of the other heroes
and lands a solid strike on the mad
Titan with Stormbreaker however he aims
for the villains chest and advertently
allowing the wounded but not at all
defeated daños to snap his fingers and
then disappear gone for the head
Thor is devastated by his failure
however a month later the Avengers
discovered anis living in retirement on
another planet and the group jumps at
the opportunity for revenge
they take Thanos into custody only to
quickly find that the Infinity stones
are destroyed and it's too late to undo
the snap in a rage Thor takes Thanos his
past advice and decapitates the villain
with a single swing
perhaps I treated you too harshly what
did you do over the following five years
Thor helps found new Asgard on earth but
he eventually leaves the bulk of the
administration to Valkyrie in the
meantime he withdraws with his friends
Korg and meek and spends his time
drinking beer playing fortnight's and
slowly slipping into an overweight
despondent state of depression the only
thing that is permanent in life is
impermanence eggs breakfast no I'd like
a Bloody Mary when Hulk and rocket
arrive at new Asgard five full years
after the snap they attempt to recruit
Thor into the Avengers effort to travel
back in time and undo the damage that
Thanos has caused while Thor is
initially reluctant he finally agrees to
join the venture when he's promised a
whole lot of beer from there the Odinson
finds out that his task is to
time-travel with rocket back to Asgard
in 2013 to the very day when his mother
dies in order to retrieve the ether once
an Asgard though Thor panics and
attempts to flee from his
responsibilities leaving rocket to take
care of the unpleasant business all on
his own
in the meantime Thor has a heart to part
with his mother and finds new hope
summoning meal near he joins rockets and
the two head back to the present
arriving at the Avengers facility in
upstate New York
once the Infinity stones are all
gathered Thor offers to be the one to
snap his fingers while wearing Starks
infinity gauntlet since he's clearly the
strongest Avenger however he eventually
defers to Hulk who takes on the
responsibility due to his affinity with
gamma radiation after this Thor
supercharged once again plays a heroic
parts in the final battle to overthrow
Thanos wielding bulk meal near and
Stormbreaker until he lends the former
to the very worthy Captain America
eventually Tony Stark gives his life to
snap Thanos to ashes and once again the
avenged
save the day so what's next for for the
Asgardian finally finds himself free to
forge his own path for the first time in
ages he surrenders his kingship to the
extremely capable Valkyrie and then
hitches a ride with the guardians of the
galaxy a move that immediately causes
friction between him and the cruise
captain star-lord
we'll just have to wait until the
November 2021 release of Thor love and
thunder to find out what the future has
in store for the mighty Odinson aside
from the timely return of his ex Jane
Foster I'm sorry to hear that Jane
dumped you she didn't dump me to dump to
the mutual dumping check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]